o pessoal de 20 e hoje vou ensinar o que
fazer com um pássaro que o bater de asas
com a ajuda de um sistema mecânico
aí é só isso o batatas e não serve para
nada além de enfeitar e mandar pra você
cara é meu país vocês deixaram piada
espaço levou ensinados a seguida como
fazê lo e vou começar o que ensinar a
par do origami velocidade de uma folha
com tamanho a4 podem usar a impressora
caderno sei lá
é importante que o tamanho a4 faça um
triângulo exógenos discutirem a pátria
claro que ficou fora
eu vou usar uma tesoura mas se vocês
quiserem podem vincar bem e rasgar com
cuidado sobre o triângulo vão ter um
quadrado profae depois tem que fazer uma
diagonal foi acertar com o primeiro a 90
graus
virem ao contrário e dobre a mãe
já agora o que vai acontecer quando
vocês chegarem à exceção das linhas se
afigura solo vem pra cima e isso
facilita bastante espaço aqui é só vocês
não virar enquadrado ao contrário isso
não vai acontecer aqui então para
facilitar vocês têm que vir a configurar
ao contrário
como eu vou mostrar a pequim e vejam
agora e esta para um lado em que em cima
da parte do outro lado e para que
ficasse uma para uma icônica é não dobra
ela porque vão fazer isso já no passo
seguinte agora esta parte sim mas
somente conic é dobrado desta maneira
aqui já não tinha muita tensão
um caso estranho falar o contrário e
triângulo para o outro a que têm que
fazer o mesmo que fizeram do outro lado
mas presta para aqui pra ficar
assimétrico
vou ensinar como fazer esse passeio
batalhas mas existem outros um pouco
mais complicados mas são diferentes
vocês quiserem podem usar o mesmo
sistema mecânico mancha usando passos de
frente
e à parte os azuis já tá feito
agora só falta fazer o pescoço eo bico
feijão que enquanto durarem partos cosa
uma continuação da linha da cauda até a
linha do discurso aqui para esta partida
um pouco mais complicado você tem que
virar ao contrário vai ficar um pouco
machucado mas no final vocês tenham tudo
vai ficar me ficou truncado hispanic
ajustei e ficou bom para finalizar só
tem que dobrar o bico marca aí tem que
fazer o mesmo que fizeram no pescoço já
está em batalha se vocês ficarem a cauda
mas eu vou fazer agora é base e para
baixo usar vários pontos de picolé
mas se vocês quiserem podem usar dois
ramos então duas réguas e cola uma raiva
na outra
realmente agora vou pensar que podia ter
usado os legos que ficava muito mais
fácil e mais rápida
junto com eles também podem usar dois
ramos lá fora têm mais ou menos direito
e vocês têm que juntar assim em el eo
uma das partes do el tem que ficar assim
uma espécie de pra mim é como vocês
podem ver lá até dos rótulos que tem
mais aumento em 15 centímetros
é importante você usar em alguns
proteção porque quando cortar um
pouquinho de picolé foi fazer uma para
ficar na nossa mão mas a outra vai
saltar então conversaram com exportação
por pode voltar para a vossa cara
envolvido e eu vou contar um pouquinho
do modo que eu fique ligeiramente maior
com aquela que ficou por baixo
eu vou completar aquela partida da
prainha aí mais uns indica só perini e
para professar a conexão de uma parte a
outra e eu marquei stoppini por sair com
a ajuda do seu rapto parental cantora
não fica assim um corta o prefeito então
nesta parte ao se usar os lotes e além
de aumentar a resistência vai ser
importante para conectar a polícia
grande de sistema
vocês podem usar um todo você estiver lá
em casa outra coisa mas antes de abrir
um ventilador vista que é bastante
barato custa 11 paulo e inglaterra vai
investigar o que estava um euro para
tempo lá todo lado é só de montar um
sistema de som e não precisa andar à
procura do interruptor nem ver o motor
estiver em claro usar o fio é um pouco
pequeno então eu tenho uma história de
mais ou menos 5 132 pilhas usando fita e
como podem ver eu não sou patrocinado
por nenhuma das pilhas fazer um projeto
com elas depois
ele é um dos pólos dos pneus vai
funcionar agora fazer o resto do sistema
sistema das polias é uma coisa que o fez
pensar bastante foi como fazer isso aqui
é bem mais simples que vocês corta um
pedaço de cola quente em caixa lá
naquela parte da roda do motor e com
lixo vocês vão encostando e até que o
partido mais desligar
mas eu tenho aqui duas tampas com uma
grande e outra feminina e vou encaixar
uma na outra
considerado um tubo papel higiênico
então tudo aquilo de eventos usando há
pouco que seu uso na cozinha e acorda
estourar um papelão de uma caixa de
cereais que a moça e esses pedaços
populam vai evitar que o elástico salto
para fora aí vejo que marquei o centro
dessas duas partes e agora vou encaixar
tudo foi um bastante cola aqui para não
haver espaço para onde o vasco ele possa
estrear também a e agora vou fazer uma
espécie de manivela menina e até ela
ficar fixa vocês têm que encher ali com
muita cola e deixar escapar mais ou
menos 23 minutos porque era muita cola
demorará um pouco esse cara
agora vou marcar o sítio ela vai ficar
ela não pode provar na parte do motor
nem na parte do papel do game em
parceria do órgão que vai ficar em cima
em caixa é punir e sim de um tubo em
pequenino de uma caneta zero hora super
cola e vou colar um pedacinho de um
pontinho de picolé e é que eu tenho de
caneta tem ficar móvel pessoal não pode
ficar preso a nada tem que fazer agora
um furo na parte final em caixa um
pouquinho do churrasco e prendam com
cola super cola popular e um filho com a
ajuda de uma tampa da o normal
vendo aqui confio naquela partida
cilíndrica moda da caneta
e prendam com cola mas também cuidado
para não prender é um cilindro a a um
pouquinho do churrasco que eu tenho que
ficar imóvel em caixa e em posteriores
que vocês quiserem
e para finalizar tem que prender a cauda
que fizessem um corta cima e inclinada
ia para agitar o filmaram pedindo a
vocês não têm que eu acho que tentando
até que funciona a cair aí só temos o
fim eu espero que tenham gostado disso
vocês tiverem alguma sugestão melhor
pode deixar nos comentários e pronto
obrigado a desistir até a próxima copa e
é